la advertencia de las potencias
occidentales es clara si el nuevo
gobierno talibán quiere reconocimiento
se lo tendrá que ganar así lo
constataron alemania y eeuu tras una
reunión de 22 ministros de exteriores
además de oficiales de la otan la onu y
la unión europea
las noticias de ayer procedentes de
afganistán no nos hacen ser optimistas
en un gobierno de transición que no
incluye a otros grupos no es la señal
para una mayor cooperación internacional
y estabilidad en el país
esperamos que la formación de los nuevos
gobiernos envíe las señales necesarias
el talibán prometió un gobierno
inclusivo pero el nuevo ejecutivo afgano
anunciado el martes no incluya mujeres
ni representa a las diferentes etnias
afganas está conformado por el ala dura
del movimiento fundamentalista con el
ministro de interior como una de las
personas más buscadas por el fbi
estadounidense
también nos preocupan las afiliaciones y
el historial de algunos de esos
individuos entendemos que los talibanes
han presentado esto como un gobierno
provisional lo juzgaremos a él y ellos
por sus acciones
blinken visitó la base aérea de ramstein
que sirve como punto de tránsito para
los evacuados afganos el secretario de
estado aseguró que está presionando al
talibán para reactivar los vuelos
comerciales desde kabul que permitan
salir a los estadounidenses y afganos en
situación de riesgo y que todavía están
estancados en el país la situación en
afganistán sigue siendo crítica y por el
momento la onu sigue sin acceso para
mandar ayuda humanitaria